sie hat begonnen die kollisionen der
andromeda galaxie mit unserer galaxie
der milchstraße eigentlich wird sie erst
in viereinhalb milliarden jahren
erwartet doch ein us forschungsteam hat
jetzt herausgefunden
die kollision von milchstraße und
andromeda galaxie hat bereits begonnen
erwartet uns ein echtes
katastrophenszenario pixum future geht
es dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen die suche
übrigens themen macht mir doch in
unserer themengruppe aufsteller gerne
vorschläge denn oft entdeckt ihr etwas
über das ich unbedingt berichten sollte
und dass ich einfach noch nicht auf dem
schirm hatte der link ist hier unter mir
zu unserer telegramm gruppe und da
findet ihr auch den link zu den themen
vorschlägen
ich freue mich auf eure inspiration
diese kollision ist unvermeidlich unsere
heimatgalaxie die milchstraße wird mit
der nur zweieinhalb millionen lichtjahre
entfernte andromeda galaxie m 31
zusammenstoßen sie ist eine kosmische
schwester unserer milchstraße denn sie
weiß nicht nur eine ähnliche masse auf
sondern ist ebenfalls eine
spiralgalaxien zudem hat sie eine
ähnlich chaotische und bewegte
geschichte hinter sich wie unsere heimat
galaxie eine geschichte die geprägt ist
von verschmelzungen und kollision am
nachthimmel ist die andromeda-galaxie
übrigens ohne technische hilfe als
schwacher verwaschener licht weg zu
erkennen mit einer geschwindigkeit von
achtung 110 kilometern pro sekunde rasen
diese beiden giganten also aufeinander
zu und werden dann in etwa viereinhalb
milliarden jahren aufeinandertreffen so
pries er die prognosen und es handelt
sich um echte giganten in der
sogenannten lokalen gruppe bilden die
milchstraße und die andromeda-galaxie
die zwei mit abstand schwersten gebilde
fachleute meinen mit der lokalen gruppe
einer galaxien gruppe zu der etwa 35
galaxien gehören unter anderem eben
andromeda die milchstraße und der
dreiecks nebel und diese drei sind dabei
auch die mitglieder der lokalen gruppe
die am kräftigsten leuchten dicht
gefolgt von weiteren mitglied der
lokalen gruppe der großen magellanschen
wolke und damit zurück zu der
unausweichlichen kollisionen die unsere
heimat galaxien etwa viereinhalb
milliarden jahren
warten sollte von diesem zeitraum gingen
fachleute zumindest bis jetzt aus doch
ein internationales forschungsteam hat
nun einen ganz anderen zeithorizont zur
diskussion gestellt den messungen der
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
von den universitäten yale und notre
dame zufolge nämlich hat die kollision
von milchstraße und andromeda bereits
jetzt begonnen was bedeutet das für die
zukunft unserer heimatgalaxie handelt es
sich dabei tatsächlich um ein
dramatisches katastrophenszenario wie
man vielleicht annehmen könnte all diese
fragen werde ich beantworten was also
wird bei dieser gigantischen kollision
passieren möglicherweise gibt es hier
nämlich neben der milchstraße und der
andromeda-galaxie noch einen dritten
beteiligten und zwar die kleinere
dreiecks galaxie m 33 manchmal wird sie
auch als feuerrad galaxie bezeichnet sie
hat einen durchmesser von mehr als
50.000 nicht jahren und ist nach der
andromedagalaxie und der milchstraße die
drittgrößte galaxie der lokalen gruppe
von der milchstraße ist sie etwa drei
millionen lichtjahre entfernt und
fachleute halten 33 für einen begleiter
der andromedagalaxie und auch sie könnte
nach ansicht mancher fachleute eben noch
mit in die kollision geraten
doch obwohl die milchstraße und die
andromeda galaxie mit knapp 400.000
kilometer aufeinander zurasen werden die
folgen des zusammenpralls möglicherweise
gar nicht so fatal sein wie man
vielleicht denken könnte ein
katastrophenszenario steht also
wahrscheinlich nicht an denn die
abstände zwischen den sternen innerhalb
der galaxien sind gigantisch groß es
gibt eine menge platz aber dazu komme
ich gleich es gibt nämlich einen
tatsächlichen katastrophalen nebeneffekt
für einen direkten zusammenstoss aber
bräuchte es an großen zufall auch unsere
erde hätte nach ansicht vieler forschen
da eine chance diese kollision zu
überleben fachleute gehen davon aus dass
sich das schwerefeld unserer sonne
während der kollision nur sehr langsam
verändern würde und so ist es eher
unwahrscheinlich dass ein massereicher
stern dem sonnensystem so nahe kommen
würde dass er dieses zerreißt aber
anders dagegen bei den äußeren planeten
dem körper gürtel und die orte wolke die
ebenfalls am rand des sonnensystems
liegen das risiko dass diese objekte von
einem anderen nahegelegenen stern
beeinflusst werden ist deutlich höher
und das könnte wieder objekte ins innere
des sonnensystems katapultieren und ein
bombardement von ass
auf die erde auslösen klar ist auch dass
bei der kollision zwischen der
milchstraße und der andromeda-galaxie
etwas ziemlich großes neues entstehen
würde
eine mega galaxie die sowohl neue als
auch altbekannte sterne beherbergt die
beiden us physiker break den haben wir
ja hier bei pixum zu um nur mehr
interviewt und thomas jd kopf schlagen
als name für das fusionsprodukt der
beiden galaxien den begriff mikrometer
vor zusammengesetzt aus den begriffen
andromeda und milky way als
alternativangebot ist auch der begriff
mit dromedar ins rennen gebracht worden
viele wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler sprechen statt von einer
kollision lieber von einer verschmelzung
dennoch werden die beiden bisherigen
strukturen die beiden spiralgalaxien
zerstört werden berechnungen und
analysen zufolge könnte sich aus der
gemeinsamen masse am ehesten eine
elliptische galaxie bilden diese sind
weitaus seltener vertreten als die
spiralen doch besonders häufig handelt
es sich hierbei um die besonders große
exemplare doch inwieweit ist diese
kollision oder verschmelzungen bereits
jetzt schon im gange das ist ja die
hauptfrage den aktuellen messergebnisse
aus kehl und nord tritt am zufolge hat
diese kollision oder aber verschmelzung
bereits jetzt begonnen für diese
betrachtungsweise kommt es vor allem
darauf an wo man die außengrenzen einer
galaxie ansetzt und das ist ja etwas
komplex denn im gesamten kosmos ist eine
grenzziehung nicht sehr eindeutig das
verdeutlicht ein uns sehr nahes beispiel
denn die access fähre also die äußere
schicht der erdatmosphäre endet auch
nicht an einer konkreten stelle
stattdessen wird sie immer dünner und
geht damit in die lehre des
interplanetaren raum es über ein
fließender übergang quasi das
internationale forschungsteam hatte sich
das hubble-weltraumteleskop zur hilfe
genommen und damit das uv spektrum von
43 fern quasi analysiert deren licht
scheint durch den halo der
andromedagalaxie und genau das ist der
punkt mit dem griff halo mein fachleute
das was sich rings um die scheibe die
meist als die eigentliche galaxie
betrachtet wird befindet es handelt sich
um eine annähernd sphärische also
kugelförmige region in der
kugelsternhaufen und stern ströme ihren
platz haben
genauso wie eine menge an gas plasma und
wohl auch die mysteriöse dunkle materie
wenn
denn existiert ist im halo von galaxien
zu finden all das gehört also zum
sogenannten gravitative einzugsgebiet
einer galaxie bei dem halo handelt es
sich also um eine art diffuse hülle und
genau diesen andromeda helau hatte das
internationale forschungsteam jetzt
genauer im visier herausgekommen sind
dabei wirklich überraschende ergebnisse
hier ging es vor allem um die frage wie
groß und wie strukturiert dieser halo
ist eine wichtige forschungsfrage für
die fachleute und dabei geht es nicht
nur um die gravitative einflusssphäre
einer galaxie die man mit hilfe der halo
ausdehnungen offenlegen kann dazu die
beteiligten wissenschaftler und samantha
beck von der yale university
die riesigen halos um galaxien zu
verstehen ist enorm wichtig denn diese
reservoire enthalten den rohstoff für
künftige stern bildung in der galaxie
aber auch die ausströme von vergangenen
ereignissen wie supernovae der halo ist
daher voller informationen über die
vergangenheit und zukunft einer galaxie
zudem verrät die ausdehnung des halos
einiges über die gravitative
einflusssphäre einer galaxie die
aktuellen messungen legen nahe dass der
andromeda halo deutlich größer ist als
bislang angenommen konkret konnten die
forschenden spektralen signaturen von
ionisierten silizium kohlenstoff und
sauerstoff aufspüren die rund 1,3
millionen lichtjahre weit ins all hinaus
reichen das entspricht fast dem
zehnfachen durchmesser ihrer stern
scheibe und nicht nur dass an manchen
stellen könnte der andromeda halo sogar
bis zu zwei millionen lichtjahren
ausreichen das muss man sich mal
vorstellen wenn der halo der
andromeda-galaxie sichtbar wäre würde
die galaxie am nachdem mit drei mal
größer als das sternbild des großen
wagens erscheinen damit wäre sie eine
der größten strukturen überhaupt am
himmel den schätzungen der fachleute
zufolge könnten im halo unseren nachbarn
galaxie achtung wohnt 40 milliarden
sonnenmassen an ionisierten gas
enthalten sein
dieses ist offenbar aber alles andere
als gleichmäßig verteilt statt dessen
von bad sich eine komplexe struktur aus
zwei ineinander liegenden schalen auch
zu der zusammensetzung konnten die
forschenden im inneren der schale
befinden sich schwere elemente und das
gas ist weniger stark ionisiert dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam
dies geht wahrscheinlich auf die
supernova aktivität in der galaktischen
scheibe zurück die den inneren halo
direkt beeinflussen die bei den
sternenexplosion
aus geschleuderten elemente werden bis
in den inneren halo geschleudert und
bringen daher dessen strömungen und
zusammensetzung der äußere teil des
halos bewegt sich dagegen einheitlicher
ist ärmer an schweren elementen heißer
und stärker ionisiert nach ansicht des
forschungsteams erlaubt dass
möglicherweise auch rückschlüsse auf den
halo der milchstraße
basierend auf unseren ergebnissen ist es
wahrscheinlich dass die milchstraße
nicht nur eine ausgedehnte hülle aus
heißem gas besitzt sondern auch ein
zukunft galaktisches medium aus warmem
und kaltem gas das ähnlich weit
hinausreicht wie bei andromeda zur
kommen galaktisch bezeichnet nichts
anderes als dass sich das medium
kugelförmig um unsere galaxie befindet
problematisch bei der erforschung der
milchstraße ist unsere position
innerhalb der spiralgalaxie also die der
erde
dadurch ist es äußerst kompliziert deren
außenbereiche genauer zu analysieren
daher sind die ausdehnung des halo und
auch die zusammensetzung der milchstraße
bisher nur teilweise erfolg immer wieder
werden neue studien veröffentlicht die
überraschende erkenntnisse über unsere
heimat galaxie offenbar so konnte mit
hilfe des röntgenteleskop xmm erst vor
kurzem festgestellt werden dass der halo
der milchstraße wohl heißer und eisen
ärmer ist als bislang angenommen
die aktuellen messungen des
internationalen forschungsteams offenbar
ebenfalls dass sich der halo unserer
milchstraße und der halo der
andromeda-galaxie bereits überlappen
denn andromeda dass halo erstreckt sich
den aktuellen messungen sehr weit in
richtung der milchstraße auf rund der
hälfte der distanz zwischen den
eigentlichen galaxien zudem gehen die
fachleute davon aus dass auch für den
milchstraßen halo ähnliches gilt die
einflusssphären der beiden galaxien
stoßen der aktuellen studie zufolge also
bereits jetzt aneinander galaxie ohne
dunkle materie sehr spannendes thema
also anklicken anschauen und zwar hier
und abonnieren uns über diesen kanal
klicks um 10.10 future bis dann bleibt
dran